by the way rapaport sent in a new diss
track you know
these diss tracks he makes he's got a
you know he's a pretty busy guy michael
rappaport he's on like two tv shows i
know of yet he takes time like he's so
consumed with you gary and you getting
covered
that he wrote another diss track and and
i was thinking maybe like like i i like
i watch like say like matthew
mcconaughey and brad pitt and they don't
do stuff like this maybe if michael
didn't do this he could move to another
level well i gotta say on some level to
have a big uh star like michael rapaport
consumed with you and writing songs
about you do you ever does it in some
way appeal to your ego i mean i would
like a bigger store
if that's what you're asking no i'm
saying you know how paul mccartney like
he well for a while all of his songs
were about linda mccartney like you're
michael rappaport's linda mccartney you
know yeah i mean
michael rappaport is no paul mccartney
on any level of singing acting or
otherwise so i mean but
my point is that michael rappaport once
held up filming on the set of only
murders in the building to make fun of
gary he literally walked off the set to
go record a diss track but anyway here's
the latest one he's consumed with the
fact that you were not working you were
at home with covid and you could have
avoided the whole thing
[Music]
lazy gary you dumb monkey who do you
think you
are you stupid ass you're not a star
blowing off work you stupid jerk to go
see pink
like your breath your work ethic stinks
cause you're lazy
gary is lazy
[Applause]
gary is lazy
howard fired that monkey
you dummy you stupid animal yeah you're
a walking wet market put a mask on those
teeth have some dignity you've filled
the ape and retire already
take two bananas and call me in the
morning you monkey pox ridden animal
wow i mean it's vicious it's vicious
he's lovely he's a double threat howard
not funny and a bad singer
i gotta get i agree with gary it was a
little out of his range it was a little
out of here i don't think he put much
into that uh you know i really don't
think he are you saying michael is lazy
rapaport's lazy